the truth will set me free I don't care
much about truth or I don't care about
the definition of truth that most people
live by I don't think truth in fact are
the same thing I think truth is an
incredibly subjective individual thing
the first time I started writing a
million little pieces I've been
searching for a voice for years and
years and years and one day I sat down
and I started writing that book and I
wrote the first sentence and it felt
right it felt more right than anything I
had ever written and so I kept going and
over the course of a couple days I wrote
probably the first 15 or 20 pages of it
and I had never worked that fast before
I was kind of stunned by it at the end
of it I looked at those pages and I was
like I did it this is what I've always
this is how I've always been trying to
write this is the voice I've always been
trying to find that book coming out and
the controversies related to it were
obviously a big moment for me but
probably not in the ways people might
think you know I didn't write that book
as a memoir I've never thought of it as
a memoir we didn't submit it to
publishers as memoirs even though it was
published as one when the controversy
blew up and you know I was sort of
written off by the publishing business
and by the literary community instead of
being upset about it I was kind of
excited I was like you know I had to
work within your system I wrote a book
that wasn't what it was published as I
always knew I wasn't born to work in
that system and it and I and I won't
ever do it again
you know from that point forward I was
free I got kicked out of a club I didn't
want to be a part of and it was awesome
since then I've literally done what I
want I call it what I want I don't say I
write fact or fiction I don't write
novels or memoirs or you know narrative
nonfiction I just write books I tell
stories the expectations and rules and
conventions
of the literary community or the
publishing community or society in
general mean absolutely nothing to me
what means something to me is telling a
story and the way I think is the right
way to do it and if I need to use
factual elements or fictional fictional
elements or things that live in the gray
area between if I have to use grammar of
my own invention if I have to lay the
pages out even at this point in my
career I publish my books how I want you
know I don't publish through
conventional publishers anymore I
publish through an art gallery I publish
my books online myself the million
little pieces controversy really freed
me to be as radical as I want to break
every rule I want and to not have to
care what other people thought it was
great